yeah I mean I think it is like one of
the happiest moments in my life at least
uh was being able to give my dad his
retirement yeah yeah because my dad had
me very very late in his life and has
been like [__] Giga Chad working his
ass off to provide for me his entire
life uh especially since my mom has had
a lot of health issues in her life as
well so a lot of it stems from my dad
having to you know put the hours in uh
and there was a point when I quit for
YouTube that he did not know if he was
going to be able to retire because I'm
an only child and I don't have any
brothers or sisters to uh prop up the
family it was all on me basically
so my dad went to like massive massive
[__] stress uh he passed retirement
age and he kept working because I still
like hadn't let's say like made it then
um and you know he kept working his
office so he was waiting for you to kind
of I suppose have money to give to him
is that no no he was waiting until I was
stable enough oh he didn't want to quit
just in case hey God needs some help
yeah yeah that makes sense okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah because he always wants
to like I remember him telling me once
that uh at one point he was like I guess
uh he just had accepted that he would
just be working until like he passed
away and you know that that [__] hit
me when I heard it so I was like [__] I
really really want to make this work not
just obviously for myself but because I
want to give my dad his retirement and
you know the I I will never forget the
moment where I you know I was able to
like say Hey Dad
we're financially stable and that was
the moment where I kind of like you know
said that we've paid off the mortgage
for the family house that we've been
paying off as a family for like years
and years uh and then you could like for
like I I saw like the strings of tension
just like just like completely like
Castle yeah just everything snapped in
years
hey let's go they said I want to be able
to make a career now I have look at them
now yeah and uh my dad just literally
just like collapsed on the sofa and
that's I hope my dad didn't remind me
telling the story but like that's the
first time I like has ever have ever
seen like my dad like shed a tear oh and
I was just like holy [__] this is this
this is what I've been working for and
now I'm like okay I'm I'm satisfied I'm
happy with my life now I'm I'm happy I'm
like monk mode activated I am satisfied
with what I've achieved and anything
else now is a bonus and a New Journey
for me I take it back ballet doesn't get
you the most rest paying your parents
retirement
that's the ultimate move yeah and I'm
glad my dad can enjoy his retirement
fully now even though he was working way
harder than he should have been for a
person who's there so how is your dad
spending his retirement
learning guitar actually he is he wakes
up and he learns guitar and uh just
reading books and I'm like that's what I
want that's what I want My Head retired
oh yeah oh yeah he works oh he works so
he hasn't retired well he found no no he
doesn't work he just helps people build
stuff oh so he can't he's kind of it's
not and now he's done now he's like
remodeling the house oh that's gonna
send me updates if literally the house
looks like a hurricane hit it
they get an open plan
remodeling of a house here yes so yeah
he's he's doing a lot of that yeah hell
yeah I'm jealous my dad just knows how
to do stuff yeah he's like yeah there's
uh the Plumbing's broken oh yeah I know
how to fix it like how how do you know
how to fix it who told you this why I
didn't know why wasn't I taught this
yeah do you have do you ever feel like
there's life skills that people just
know and you're like where did people
learn this from yeah I mean anything to
do with like just fixing everything yeah
any skill involving any tools for so
let's fix something I'm just like how
where who taught you this for me it's
cars like anything to do with cars like
I I remember one time I had this uh I
was in like Ireland in Ireland with
Sydney
um and then you know we had a rental car
and we were just driving around uh it
broke down yeah like in the middle of
Ireland and I was like would you what
did people what'd you do what what am I
supposed to do I'm like I I know maybe
I'm supposed to call the AAA does the
AAA exist here do we need insurance what
uh what what is the process and I
because I just realized I had just never
been taught this or I had never been
taught how to change a flat tire if
you'd if I'd like ever had a if if you
ever got a flat tire in in the middle of
the road right and I was just like I I
am just so unequipped with this life
skill that people I think people are
supposed to know I have just never
experienced it yeah well Counterpoint
yes I think that's because there's this
whole level of information that is like
stuff you should know but you don't need
to know them now because in two seconds
you can watch a YouTube video on how to
do it right like I think learning how to
change a tire yes you should know how to
do that without having to do it but I
think the reason why people don't feel
so pressed to learn it is because yeah
if it happens and let's say you have all
the gear with you you're like all right
well let's watch the Youtube video I
hope it's a good tutorial you can just
watch someone explain it yeah and you're
like okay uh and even if I knew how to
do something like change attire I think
I would just watch the video just to be
like I need to make sure yeah and I
don't [__] this off sure do you know how
to change the talk uh I think if you
gave it to me I think I could do it
I think that's so confident I know why I
think it's the kind of thing where like
if I was with like a friend of mine who
was [__] themselves I would lie
about it and be like yeah I know what
I'm doing I'm always that guy and
whenever someone is like freaking out
I'm like yeah of course I know what I'm
doing and I'm like yeah I don't know the
details but I know like the basic steps
I'm like
because the thing is the thing is I had
I had to be that guy so I'm explaining
it I'm explaining Sydney's like she's
like I don't know what to do yeah I'm
explaining my internal thoughts because
what happens is we break we break down
we break down the middle of the road and
Sydney's like oh what do we do and this
I I I'm like don't worry I got it let me
check let me check what's going on I get
out of the car I walk around and I'm
like it's broken I have no idea I'm just
acting like I do so Sydney doesn't
[__] panic because we're in we're in
a country we don't live in we know we
know nobody here yeah so I'm like all
right let me let me just check the
engine let me just check the water I
have no idea what that means you're
basically just staring at the engine for
20 seconds
I think I know I literally open up the
hood and I'm like when I was with my dad
he would always check the water so
that's what I'm going to do I don't know
what that really means I'm just gonna
check the water level and then I've
opened up the hood I checked the water
level and I just start googling [__]
as I went on
um yeah I mean I think there's a lot of
information that we aren't taught
because everyone just I think assumes
that ah you'll be able to figure it out
yeah like I think that stuff like that
is like that yeah so I think that like
the fact that at least in the UK and I
think the US and whatever I think they
don't teach you anything about how to be
responsible with your money this is like
the one that always comes up right taxes
and all that the fact that we aren't
taught any of that is wild to me yeah
because I'm like that is some [__] we
all have to deal with and it [__] you
in the ass if you don't do it right you
get [__] for life you [__] up those
people I never knew how to do my taxes
or get a [__] mortgage or like any of
that [__] I wish someone taught me that
[__] yeah I I wish someone told me that
I'm flailing around like an interesting
thing you should be taught yeah it's not
like Google like that we definitely need
to be taught like hey uh just because
credit cards say they give you money uh
there's a lot of bad things that could
happen if you [__] it up so maybe don't
use the credit card you really really
think you can handle it like I was never
taught to me I didn't even know what the
difference between a credit card on the
debit card was until I was like like 19
or 20 and I'm like I've been using this
for two years
if if something breaks in your house do
you know who to call yeah if my dad
I think I legit would be like hey Dad do
you think it's just like a serious thing
or a thing I should say yeah what do you
think our dad's learning from do you
think they're just making this [__] up
as because I I don't feel like that and
I don't feel like they are but I like to
think that every time some [__] breaks
down in my house and I call my dad and
I'm like yeah Dad so I got this problem
what can you do he's like yeah hold on
son let me check he just opened his
phone because I've never asked my dad
who taught him yeah but all I know is
that he never taught me yeah or at least
he never taught me all the intricacies
and or everything that he knows you know
so I'm like what the [__] did he learn
it from uh
they weren't wasting their damn time
loving these liberal arts courses they
were learning how to run trucks yeah
because you know when I you know when I
eventually have as a kid when it whether
it's a son or daughter I'm sure they're
gonna ask me about stuff right right
you're gonna reach that point in your
life where your your kid's gonna ask you
about stuff uh and you're gonna have to
pretend like you know what the [__]
going on well it's like maybe the kid
will be like hey hey Dad how do you uh
install the server or something this
thing you'll be like well and he's gonna
be like how the [__] does my dad know
how to do this it's like well you just
had to learn it when you were then like
right I think that's just like like we
have to we have to just learn everything
about the internet and using it I'm sure
to our whatever the kids that come along
they'll be like how the [__] do they
know all this stuff yeah you know yeah
I'm sure I'm sure how do they use the
sponsor today's video especially
it'd be funny if it's actually sponsored
how do they make a clickbait title yeah
I'm sure it's like something that we you
just grow up learning and then it seems
like crazy because they had like 40
years worth of knowledge yeah that
occasionally comes in handy right who
taught you guys how to shave I knew
you're gonna ask me I had a feeling
about this I had the sixth sense you're
gonna break okay was it okay I told
myself really my dad told me I [__] it
up for a very my dad told me and I
[__] it up was okay so your dad told
you yeah did you have to like ask him
father teach me how to shave or was
there like a was there like a day where
you're down my dad just said you your
face looks like a toothbrush let's
[__] get rid of that [__] and then he
was like he took me to the the bathroom
sink and he was like all right I'm gonna
teach you how to say
and then he was like all right bring a
roll of toilet paper because you're
probably gonna cut yourself multiple
times which I did yes and then I still
kill myself yeah and then and then after
maybe he he was with me you know to make
sure I was like doing it correctly maybe
like two or three times and then at one
point I was like yeah I got it figured
it out so like we forced it I'll figure
this [__] out God damn I still don't
think I've perfectly figured this out
because I guess like when like I had to
go to my dad to ask him I was like Hey
Dad how do you shave and he never looked
like more happy and excited about that
he's just like oh oh I get I got a
father-son moment
um he told me I I'm sorry it's going out
call you out for this Dad but he taught
me that okay yeah I mean you can't use
shaving cream uh soap's fine as well
and and so for my entire life I've just
like never and you guys figure this out
when I was shaving when we were like on
holiday yeah but I've never like used
shaving cream for most of my life I've
just used I've just used showers and the
fact that yeah and the fact that your
skin is like impeccable is just like not
fair anyway maybe my dad was on to
something I I don't know I know you I
know in Desperate situations I've used
conditioner what yeah conditioner works
as well really it was just about having
like a I think it's like a just a
barrier right you see something in the
way that's smooth and that you can still
shave through if I don't have the option
then I just don't shave I'm just like
I'll wait till I'm actually yeah but I I
look homeless if I don't sometimes I'd
look almost with or without it so it
doesn't really matter for me